we are not yet able to say
that the dam is breaking when it comes
to republicans and gun safety
regulations in fact it's not breaking in
total but we are starting to see some
cracks as multiple republicans including
an nra endorsed republican are now doing
a 180 and saying it's time for gun
safety regulations something has to be
done i have two examples of that for you
we're first going to look at an
interview that republican congressman
adam kinzinger did on cnn now caveats
adam kinzinger is leaving congress okay
adam kinzinger is not a trump republican
he is an anti-trump republican and so
some people will write him off and say
he's not really a republican because of
that but this is a republican who for a
long time opposed banning assault style
rifles
and now he said it's something he's open
to this is a major change take a look at
this congressman you do still oppose a
ban on the kind of assault weapons that
were used in the shooting can you
explain why private citizens need
weapons of war
look i have opposed a ban uh you know
fairly recently i think i'm open to a
band now it's going to depend what it
looks like because there's a lot of
nuances on what constitutes you know
certain things but i'm getting to the
point where i have to wonder maybe it's
maybe somebody to own one maybe you need
an extra license maybe you need extra
training and so the question is is it a
band versus an additional certification
but yeah i got to tell you i mean that
99.9 of people that own ars we all know
are not going to walk into a school and
do this
but the problem is for those that
support the second amendment like me
we have to be coming to the table with
ways to mitigate 18 year olds buying
these guns and walking into schools my
side's not doing that right my side's
not coming forward with reasonable ways
to defend an amendment that we think is
very important and so i'm looking at
this going fine if people are going to
put forward solutions about certifying
maybe who can buy an assault weapon
i'm certainly open to that so listen
it's no big gun safety declaration
he's leaving congress he's saying maybe
it's just more restrictions and not
really banning them but it's a change
and it's an important change now the
reality is that a ban alone isn't enough
to really interrupt the school shooting
fiasco we have in this country but it's
maybe one part and i talked about that
in my list list of 10 specific gun
safety proposals that i outlined last
week it's also important to mention
kinzinger still voted with trump 90 of
the time while trump was president um
but listen he's willing here okay and so
let's let's praise it for what it is and
not go overboard now here's another
example then chris jacobs who's a
straight-up nra endorsed congressman
from new york after the buffalo shooting
he also says that his perspective has
changed there's a great piece in the
buffalo news
which says
congressman chris jacobs of orchard park
made a surprising about face on gun
control issues becoming perhaps the
first congressional republican
to call for an assault weapons ban in
the wake of the recent mass shootings in
buffalo and duvalde texas at a news
conference and later with the buffalo
news jacobs who was endorsed by the nra
in 2020 laid out a series of new stances
that run contrary to the republican
party line on guns in addition to saying
he would vote for a democratic bill
banning assault weapons he also said he
would back raising the age on some gun
purchases to 21. my suggestion was 25
but 20 21 is something limiting the
capacity of magazines i agree and
banning the sale of military-style body
armor to civilians in the interview
jacob said the two recent shootings
forced him to reevaluate his position on
guns and to research where he wanted to
stand in the future
so what can we say
i can't say the dam is breaking the nra
is incredibly strong but there are
cracks starting to form and it really
remains to be seen
whether this will
uh become anything and whether anything
will happen or not this could start to
achieve change or at least start putting
pressure on people
to make a change and it's very
interesting adam kinzinger chris jacobs
let's see who else had themselves to the
list the claim in washington is that
this is different
now we've heard that a thousand times
before because we've had a thousand or
more mass shootings um
but uh it remains to be seen whether
that will be the case